this morning a return visit from rich
cohen cohn is written about pirates
gangsters the rolling stones religion
and his beloved chicago sports teams
just to name
a few all of it's made him one of the
rangiest and most prolific authors
in america this week he's out with a new
book that may be his most
personal yet it's about him and his
family his son specifically
in the wild and crazy world of youth
sports hear that pass
there is not much in life better than
passing a ball or puck back and forth
with your kid
go to the net it's a little thing
but also everything with the exquisite
highs that come with bonding over
sports however come the inevitable lows
and rich cohen
has done a damn fine job documenting
both in his latest book
peewees confessions of a hockey parent
this can consume your life it does
consume my life
this is this welcome to my house we met
cohen at danbury ice arena in
connecticut
one of the places his youngest son
played during one
memorable season rationally i know i
shouldn't care about it and i'll tell
myself the beginning of every season
that this season is going to be
different and this season i'm not going
to care
and then i get into the stands and i
feel like i'm going to like pass out
from the intensity of it
peewees named after 11 and 12 year olds
is laid out by months of the year
as winter tightens its grip and cohen's
son's team inches
toward a regional tournament these are
not after school pickup games
their matches both early morning and
late night
long weekends of travel and one parent
taking a hard look
at everything that went down cohen
doesn't leave out much drama
you talk about arguments with coaches
you talk about getting very angry
with little kids your wife had to pull
you away
from the sport for a while and wouldn't
even let you go right
i mean i went i lost my mind and it's
stupid
and it's not important it's so maybe the
fact that it is stupid and it's not
important is what makes it so important
it's like cheering for sports in general
yeah it's like my father grew up with
larry king
larry stoy says sports is the most
important unimportant thing in the world
and that's why you lose your mind over
because it's almost like
you transfer everything from the rest of
the world into this ring
and that's when people act really bad
when they when the game
becomes a symbol for everything and it
becomes unfortunately a lot more
important for the parents than
than the kids but that's the blessing
see one of the reasons why i think
hockey is the best sport is the
plexiglass
because the parents are up there yelling
but the kids can't hear them
right now most youth sports are either
on pause or dramatically scaled back
but that wasn't the case as cohen's book
builds to a series of youth games in
lake placid
home 40 years ago to another group of
amateurs
and the greatest american sports moment
of the 20th century
hockey's miracle on ice
you say in the book you said when it's
functioning like it's supposed to youth
hockey
is one of the few communities where
america still works yes
what does that mean every kid on the ice
can score at any time every kid's
involved every kid's important
and it's like horses pulling a cart
so basically it means that it really is
a meritocracy
it really is the best kids playing
together playing with kids at your level
and playing as a true team where
everybody has to sublimate to some
degree
their own talent and their own ego and
their own desire
to make the whole thing go
he's gotten good and he's different now
than he was when you wrote the book
yeah he's playing with really good
players so he's gotten good because play
with better players you get better or
you quit
basically we won't spoil the ending of
peewees
but like it or not if you're a parent
you'll likely see at least some of
yourself
inside you'll see your kids too and it
might help you take everything
a little less seriously or not
at the end of all this do you feel like
by writing this book you fixed whatever
went wrong
no probably not i mean i thought maybe
you know and then now because of the
kovid we're not really playing these
games
but there was a game there was one game
early in the season i'm like i'm a
totally different person i've written
this book
i've come to deal with it and i went to
the game it was in new jersey
and my son was sitting when i thought he
should be playing you know he was
sitting too much
and i felt it well up in me i felt the
old beast coming back so i'm like
you know that's when you go outside and
count back counting backwards from 10
is very important for a hockey parent
eight so you can you can i can totally
relate
my son played basketball and it was like
mom could you please
just yeah that's down karen's end up and
it's the counting backwards the
more important thing is what the when he
talks about the coaches in the book the
24-hour rule and that is all the parents
trying to
get their comments in and and talk about
the game after the coach is like
24 hours you sleep on it you wait we can
talk about it tomorrow which is probably
what more people should do that is
social media and everything else exactly
we are new hockey parents by the way
right now congratulations learning how
to experience this
i think it's great the kids love it and
he's right they're all so involved